they're all funny they're all great you
love them but the one person who just
cracked you up Sasso yeah yeah well
always will and will also like Sasso and
Mo Collins
they're all great but but but Sasso and
Mo and then and then Sasso specifically
just because like
there was the least amount of age gap
between me and him and every other cast
member and um it was the year that
tenacious D's album had come out so like
I'm just a ball of nerves and like
feeling undeserving unward like what am
I doing here I'm a fraud and we'd hang
out in his dressing room and he'd play
the songs on guitar and we'd sing Jack
Black would play the songs yeah jackpot
did come did he he performed they
performed Tenacious D perform that year
and it's maybe the most embarrassing uh
most embarrassed I've ever felt why I
was 19 so excited that album was
everything
there they had a little stage for the
music guest and they had to put like
temporary chairs I asked the producers
can I sit in those chairs and like turn
you're you're on the show you don't and
I was like I want to sit front row and
they're like sure
um I did like this is embarrassing and I
haven't really ever admitted this in
public before anything but they played
rock your socks off yeah and I thought I
was being so clever and funny that
during the performance I slipped my
shoes off and took off my socks so that
when the song ended I threw my socks on
stage
like they'd rocked my socks off I I
don't think I think that's funny it was
okay and Jack of course because he's a
genius was like it worked but that's a
good impression yeah buddy hey
um
um and and so then Mike Hitchcock who is
writing on the show at the time and was
also very kind to me was I was like I
love it he's like well come meet him
they're great they're nice and I go in
Jack's sitting on the floor like uh
cross-legged like signing vinyls and
then Kyle Gass is there sitting on the
couch talking to some friend their
managers in there and Mike comes in and
goes hey Jack how are you and they know
each other a little bit and Jack's like
good to see you buddy how you doing and
like this is Taryn he's so excited to me
he's a huge fan he's our newest cast
member he's only 19. Jackson like 19
when I was your age you know
and they get to talking about things
that you know the mutual acquaintances
and I kind of sit down on this little
couch
and Mike and here talking and then Dave
Grohl walks in oh boy yeah yeah and I'm
like oh sh and Dave had played drums on
their album so he was playing drums for
them at the show
and I'm sitting on the couch and I'm
just like this is the drummer for
Nirvana I'm looking at the drummer for
Nirvana this is Foo Fighters but this is
the drummer of Nirvana and they're
talking everybody says hi and I'm just
like so Starstruck and in that time I
think Hitchcock had said goodbye and
left the room
and so I'm still there without kind of
my host guardian and but I just want to
watch all of it because I am kind of a
fly on the wall and Groll sits next to
me on this couch and he's catching up
with her manager and their other friends
and Kyle and he and I'm just sitting
there and Dave girl goes yeah yeah we're
out of my place in Virginia you know
it's great you just got a lot of space
and we do these barbecues and like the
beef is so good there we get these huge
steaks and you can kind of tell that I'm
like eavesdropping so he looks over and
like very kindly includes me and he's
like you know like huge steaks and I was
like oh I wouldn't know wasn't invited
already hating myself and he's like oh
man well maybe maybe next time I said
I'm not I promise you I am not
exaggerating any of this you're trying
to fit in I'm trying to I'm we do that
to be approved of course and and and
acknowledged and he already did too and
I just was not cool enough to be like oh
that's nice you man you know I'm like he
goes oh well maybe next time I go oh
thanks but um not allowed in the state
of Virginia
and he goes really why is that and I
said oh well I'm not uh legally allowed
to say let's let's just say it has
something to do with sodomy and cows
like just the most base dumb moronic
trying to be funny Grote like 19 year
old bro whatever love you after that no
I I no I'm in the moment I'm going like
shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up
stop stop shut up and at that horrible
whatever lame thing he's like all right
man and his body kind of shifts you know
and like